You're Hank Henshaw. The Real Hank Henshaw.
You survived?
Yes, I survived.
Good luck with that.
My turn.
Why are you doing this?
Because it's time for you to die!
you and the rest of the alien scum, have no place on this planet
Hank Henshaw is dead. I am Cyborg Superman.
Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie.
This is going to be my Cyborg Superman comics
versus TV show versus movies video so there's
been a bunch of different versions of the
character so I'm going to start with the comics
and work our way to the TV show so the cool
thing about Cyborg Superman is what you most
of my memories of him as a child were from
the Reign of the Superman era and actually
killed Superman off in the comics big big
event they debuted all these pretenders to
the throne amongst them was the Hank Henshaw
who is Cyborg Superman, but the big twist
is that you didn't learn the Cyborg Superman
was evil till much much later in that storyline
you only knew him as the Cyborg Superman you
didn't know he was secretly Hank Henshaw,
so the funny thing about Hank Henshaw is he
was created it is a bit of a rift kind of
a joke on fantastic four's origin story family
and friends on a mission in outer space for
Lex Corp. get hit by solar radiation it is
all kinds of crazy stuff to their biology
and eventually Hank Henshaw ends up uploading
his mind to a computer.
So he becomes artificial intelligence all
the weird stuff that happens to his crew because
of the solar radiation ends up being this
big run and was Superman.
So eventually he's able to rescue his wife,
but when he appears to her as this artificial
intelligence unit was like this cobbled together
machinery she full lips commit suicide in
Hank Henshaw valves revenge against Superman
blaming him for all the problems they've had.
So before Superman could take them down.
He transmits his intelligence to Superman's
pod takes off and outer space for parts unknown
never to be heard from again till the Reign
of the Superman storyline so while in outer
space of eventually he hatches this plan with
Mongol on war world to take down Superman
and it becomes like this big arc that ropes
in Green Lantern and spun into a big Green
Lantern Hal Jordan storyline where he was
possessed by parallax.
So eventually he winds up on Apokolips which
was really fun storyline later in the most
people remember him from the war of light
because he became part of the Sinsestro Corps
he'd taken over the manhunters so the manhunters
became a tool of the Sinestro Corps.
So if you haven't read it be like you've seen
pictures of him wearing the lantern rings
like this really bad ass arc.
That's from Geoff Johns storyline, so he's
a super bad ass character but he actually
became more like a Green Lantern character
eventually in the comic that was with that
Manhunter storyline was and then the real
twist becomes sad he just wants to die but
because of the way his artificial intelligence
hiss consciousness works he just keeps surviving
even though he does not want to live anymore
he helps out the anti-monitor in exchange
for the anti-monitor killing him that doesn't
go down very well.
Later he tries to get Nekron to kill him during
blackest night still can't get them to do
that and then becomes a prisoner of star labs
before the big new 52 reboot.
So recently in the new Supergirl rebirth comic
of version of Cyborg Superman surfaces but
it's actually so rail her father and it's
a bit of a smaller story like as not quite
is crazy and sprawling is the death and return
of Superman becomes more of a storyline of
her sacrificing her humanity in order to get
back her family is a slightly different spin
on the character you know like very different
from the Hank Henshaw is Cyborg Superman in
the roof the reason he kept coming back for
Superman but thus far the closest thing we've
seen to Cyborg Superman in the movies is actually
the animated movie Superman doomsday where
Lex creates a clone, but it's an amalgam of
Superboy, Connor Kent and Cyborg Superman
in the comics so it's not true Cyborg Superman,
but I definitely think they could use the
character in the DC extended universe eventually
there working on the 2nd Man of Steel movie
it's still a long ways off so it's going to
be a long time before we see it.
But as a Superman villain he's actually a
pretty solid pick.
He's a huge middle finger to Superman, so
I could totally see Lex Luther trying to clone
Superman in some way or create an artificial
Superman just something really evil that walks
around wearing his face but now to explain
the TV show version because they are doing
Hank Henshaw Cyborg Superman, but it's a bit
of a twist because he wears the same face
is Martian Manhunter, so is more of a Cyborg
green Martian but he does have some of Kara's
DNA.
So he looks more like comic book Cyborg Superman,
but it's more of a Martian Manhunter twist
on it, but because of that I don't think that
he'll be wearing the Superman Symbol straight
up comic book Cyborg Superman, so it is a
vast departure in that sense, but he is using
the Fortress of Solitude with Kara's DNA.
So he's slightly more important for Martian
Manhunter's character development at this
point than he is for Kara's character development,
but that just remains to be seen.
Here's my question for you guys.
How do you want them to use the character
in the new DC live action movies if they wanted
to do a Superman clone they kind of already
did a kryptonian amalgam clone that was what
doomsday was.
So I'm not expecting them to do Superboy,
anytime soon.
Like Connor Kent, but they could do a version
where they combine storylines like that in
the future they want to get really crazy was
Superman villains in the movies they would
probably do Parasite or they might even just
use some of the forces of Apokolips like there
are a bunch of people that won't be in the
Justice League movie that they can just pull
off the bench if you're looking for really
good Cyborg Superman comic book story to read
I would recommend just the Reign of the Superman
arc through the destruction of coast city
and then later the Revenge of the Green Lanterns.
So Cyborg Superman versus the Green Lantern
Corps and the Sinestro Corps War which is
an amazing Green Lantern storyline both solid
picks.
So what's going to happen next is there's
new Flash tomorrow Killer Frost.
So be sure to subscribe to get that video
there is a new round of the DC giveaway to
all you have to do to enter that is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video some of
you have also been asking for a Black Panther
video they announced a whole bunch of the
cast, so i might make a video for that before
I post my Flash video, so whole bunch of stuff
happening this week.
Happy Thanksgiving everybody that Celebrates
Thanksgiving this week.
While you guys wait for that to post you can
click here for the big Crossover Trailer and
you can click here to watch the Killer Frost
Flash trailer thank you so much watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys tonight!